Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad. And I'm Robert Krulwich. And this is radiolab,
the podcast and not Radiolab the, the real show. Other one.
No,
this is a shorty in this podcast we're gonna take you to New York City to the
92nd street y where I do a series called giants of science.
And on one night something very cool happened with Amy answer.
I thought you were, I thought I saw you there in row three,
but I can't remember anything I tell him. Tell him I'll set up the guest is,
well, I'm not even, I don't have to,
let's just go to the hall and Robert on tape. We'll take over from here.
The, the man you are about to me is,
he's a professor at Columbia University of mathematics.
He's also a professor of Physics at Columbia University.
He's also the director of the Institute for Strings,
cosmology and Astro Particle Physics at Columbia University.
He's also a best selling author.
He's also done work in what's called mirror symmetry,
which means I'm not sure what exactly, uh, it involves my,
my relating to different Columbia manifolds or letting the kind of fold to one
of the orbit folds, which I'm sure you know all about. He's a road scholar.
He's the author of the elegant universe of basically, he's not a dumb person,
not at all, but he does however,
believed the most peculiar things. So if you ask him, and I will,
he believes that if you travel from this room,
from this auditorium on 92nd street and Lexington Avenue in pretty much any
direction at all, but if you have to go really, really, really far,
light years upon light, years upon light, years out, you will,
if you travel far enough, eventually find a galaxy and,
but let it looks and I mean exactly like our Milky Way.
And in that galaxy you will find a planet that is an absolute copy,
a dead ringer for our planet earth.
And on that planet you will find a city that is uncannily down to the hairs on
the city rats.
Exactly like this city in New York City and in that city there will be another
92nd street, y, W Y, m, h. A.
Were they building it as another auditory minute?
That is exactly like this auditorium here and if you think that's an unlikely
coincidence,
I'm just getting started because I think Brian can will also tell you that in
that distant distant distant auditorium on the other side of the cosmos
backstage waiting to come on stage,
there is a nother professor who also teaches both mathematics and physics at his
school. That just happens to also be called Columbia University,
who's also the director of Written Institute for Strings,
cosmology and Astro particle physics who also just happens to be named Brian
Green with an e on the end. Like this one,
the one out here who happens to have an identical set of also two sisters and
the same mother and the same father with the same memories down to what he ate
this morning for breakfast,
which would not be an egg because the far away Brian Green,
like the nearby Brian Green are both of them vegans and we're not. We're not,
we're not favoring vacants tonight we're just mentioning Vegas and in these two
rooms, these two identical professors with their identical paths are going to be
talking to yes and identical audience watching. What'd you do?
The exact copy of every one of you sitting here in this room right now with all
your histories and all your memories,
your exact copies are sitting in that other room on the other side of the
universe, including you.
You in particular and you [inaudible] and if you think no self-respecting
Columbia University professor would actually, I don't mean this poetically,
but actually believe that there's a copy of us on the other side to make it even
crazier.
Brian Green believes there's not only one doppelganger room with a doppelganger.
Brian meaning the doppelganger audience, he leads.
There are countless doubles of us in every direction out there in the great
beyond and what's more,
there are rooms exactly like this one with just you missing or just me missing
or the color of my shirt. Slightly different. In other words,
any big enough cosmos in an infinite cosmos, Brian Green, things that,
anything you could imagine,
almost anything that can be out there will be out there really out there to
which I say, oh good,
cause you really believe this. And if so, why? So let's ask him.
Let's welcome the local homegrown version of a man. I like to call Brian Green.
[inaudible]
so far so good. Did I get it right? More or less?
There's an assumption you left out, but we can get to that. Okay.
Let's talk about two words, infinite and universities to infinite.
First we're going to start by discussing what you have in a manuscript you're
working on. Now you've described it as the amalgam,
Imelda Marcos wardrobe problem. So we, we, we,
we have a woman here who does not like c being seen in the same outfit twice.
So tell us what, how she solved it.
Ah, that's an interesting way to get into the subject.
I didn't anticipate that that is where we would begin, but that's good. Um, the,
the issue that you're referring to is the following.
If you have a finite number of distinct ways in this particular case of
dressing, right,
and you have say an infinite number of days and evenings on what you have to
step out,
then it's pretty clear that you're going to have to repeat an outfit once,
twice,
in fact innumerable times because you only say had 10 different outfits.
Or in the case of Emelda, the example there,
I forget how many hundred dresses and 1000 pairs of designer shoes, right?
There you go.
So you can envision the number of distinct combinations of dresses and shoes.
Very easy to figure it out just 500 times a thousand.
And then if they're more than that many days,
then that individual that Amelda is going to have to repeat is going to have to
repeat a given outfit if they're say infinitely many days and only find it
number of outfits. Simple idea. So just to make it simpler,
still are clear as still, let's do it as a coin toss.
The odds against me getting say a thousand heads in a row if we're be
infinitesimal. But if I kept tossing and tossing, and if I tossed infinitely,
then of course I'm going to hit. That's right.
You do a thousand coin tosses over and over and over again,
and look at all of the outcomes.
Then even the most strange kind of outcomes will appear such as all heads.
And in fact, if you flip those coins enough times, say infinitely many times,
then that strange outcome will actually appear rarely,
but infinitely many times.
So now let's just use that logic and apply it to just a different kind of
system. Imagine a cosmos, which has into infinite space.
Now the key thing here I think is that, um,
the stuff in the cosmos you believe has some kind of finite set of rules.
So let's take a her, this woman in, in what do you, are you in the pinkish?
Kind of, yeah. Rip. Okay.
So she is a compilation of Adams,
which follows certain rules. Her memories are, I assume,
you think also Adam's. I do not.
Everybody agrees that every aspect of your personality and your conscious being
is reduceable to a configuration of the atoms that make up your brain.
But I certainly believe that. And that's [inaudible] memories. That's right.
There's nothing else.
All you are is a bag of particles acting out the laws of physics.
That to me is pretty clear. However, it does tasteful you,
the kiss of God. We just don't include in this story. You can if you'd like.
I just don't see any particular need for it. So for this discussion,
oh well come on, we got to applaud. Uh, so,
so if she is just a large number of atoms,
any particular array, but let's say she can,
um, we can travel infinitely and look at all of,
and we're talking here what I guess about particles are about forces or about,
you can reduce everything, basically two particles. That's a,
that's a fine way of phrasing the whole conversation.
And the idea that you're getting at is indeed the fact that if the universe is
infinitely big, the rough idea that we can make precise in a moment.
If it's infinitely big,
then the number of distinct configurations of particles,
like the number of distinct possible coin tosses actually is finite.
And if the universe is infinitely big than just as your coin toss is have to
repeat, the configurations of the particles will have to repeat.
So you go sufficiently far out there and the configuration of particles will
repeat and will indeed make a configuration of particles that looks just like
this room
looks on the outside or is so.
So she had a dream last night about a black cat walking on a,
on a fire escape.
She is also deeply in love with the men next to her and they share an enormous
number of of, of experiences together and she's wearing the pink thing,
the red. So we have a lot of Adam's,
they're doing very different things if indeed they're doing these things at all.
You say that that combination,
the intimate inside and outside come into here will be found elsewhere again and
again and again?
Yes. Has Mattress saying both?
I'm saying that the outside will be found with a distinct inside many places out
there,
but the outside would the same inside will also be found out there because
again,
it's just another configuration of the particles and since there are only a
finite number of distinct possibilities, that's a huge finite number.
It's the Gargantuan finite number,
but it's a finite number and if he goes sufficiently far out,
there's just so many distinct configurations that there can be if they're
finally many, so if he goes to efficiently, far out, you have to repeat,
but won't you run into a trillion people almost like her [inaudible] much easier
to reproduce this,
this woman in the first row with one particle in a different place or two
particles in different, those are much easier because there's less constraint.
If you want to reproduce this individual completely.
Every single particle has to be in the right place.
That just means you have to go a little further. Now you,
I know we're speaking here and this is, this makes perfectly logical sense.
It just makes absolutely no practical sense obviously,
but I'm also wondering whether it makes sense to you as a person.
Do you seriously think,
do you literally think that there are two people exactly like us with our
dreams,
our thoughts a little bit about it in some other stage right now or whatever you
would call now over and over again right now,
all over the universe or you just say that
[inaudible]
well,
there's a key element that we have been assuming and we've been assuming that
the universe is infinitely big and we don't know that the universe is infinitely
big. It could be that you go on for some distance and you walk in,
you walk and you wind up coming back from that direction.
Sort of like the surface of the earth. It has a certain size.
It's not infinitely big. It doesn't have an edge. You can't fall off,
but nevertheless, when you keep on going, you return to your starting point.
It could be that the universe has that kind of a shape.
The data seems not to support that at all. At the moment. The best.
Astronomical data does not support that as the parts of the universe that is
flat as opposed to curved. And if that's the case,
it's still possible that the universe could be sort of like a surface of the
earth in the sense that it might be like the surface of a video game screen.
If anybody who plays pac-man or any of the other video,
you know that you know when Ms Pacman falls off the right side of the screen,
you know she doesn't disappear. She comes back on the left side of the screen.
That's another possible shape for the university has a,
it's called the Taurus and our universe might have that particular shape. Again,
it's a finite shape, but you can't fall off.
We don't believe you can fall out of the universe.
So that would be a way to have a finite universe where you don't fall off.
However,
the other possibility is simply that it goes on forever and we don't know which
is right. The simplest one mathematically is that it's simply goes on forever.
And if that's the shape of the universe, then yes,
I fully believe that we are out there in some notion of now having this
conversation not once, not twice, infinitely, many times.
Well, aside from the deep creepy news, well let's talk about the creepiness. It,
I mean there is an, uh, a notion that we all have,
that we are unique individuals and that there is a real version of us,
in my case, you're looking at him. So you just said that a million,
billion times over in the other universities. Uh,
well, so where does that leave you?
Do you just feel like personal identity is very odd?
418 or personal identity in this context is very, very strange.
There's literally no difference between me and the other guy out there.
And that's okay with me. I don't really have a problem with that.
But I do agree that it challenges your sense of what your personal identity is
all about. You're the collection of your memories,
which are ultimately just to collection of impressions in your brain,
just the collection of particle configurations.
And if that other individual has the same brain configuration because the
particles are in a identical state as they are in my head,
that person is as much me as I am me.
So it doesn't that automatically make you want to quickly run off the stage,
hide under a pillow,
do something that the other guy could never find out and then be different.
Well, I know that he'll have exactly the same thought,
so it won't help me very much.
But that's really creepy to be chased around by the, by the,
by the infinite number of doppelgangers so that what you,
everything you will to do,
they also will to do simultaneously and there are infinitely others that will do
something slightly different. So there's just a richness to the world,
but his complexion is somewhat different than what you had in mind.
I think most of us have in mind that if the universe is infinitely big,
you keep on going. You'd see new landscapes keep on going,
you'd see new stuff, new stuff, new stuff.
That's our picture of what reality is and that kind of a universe, our universe.
And I'm saying that the laws of physics don't support that notion.
The Laws of physics support, yes, it's a rich world out there,
but the distinct landscapes, the distinct environments,
the distinct configurations that you can see are limited.
What about how far away is the nearest one to me? Well,
that's a good question. You can actually calculate that.
And as you might imagine,
it's a pretty big number because I'll give you a number from a guy named mark
Tegmark at MIT. I have no idea what this means.
What is 10 to the power of 10 to the 29th meters?
Uh, that's a big number. And um, you know,
you, you know what it means. It's not like high, it's not, not, uh, well, just,
just to quickly say what they mean is,
I think you're familiar with what tend to the two means. It's a hundred,
just a one with two zeroes following it. In this particular case,
you take 10 to the 29, that's a big number. One with 29 zeroes after it.
And then you take 10 to that number,
which is that many zeroes following tend to the 29 Zeros following the one and
it's so big that we don't have a name for, I mean called the Krulwich.
What I mean it's a,
it's a huge number and it just is commensurate with the fact that even though
we're saying that there are finite number of ways that my particles,
my electrons, my protons, my corks,
there's a finite number of distinct ways that they can be configured.
It's a huge number. So you have to flip that coin many, many,
many times before you reproduce that particular sequence,
this particular configuration. But in an infinite universe,
let me just stress and an infant universe tend to attend to the 29 is really
small.
I mean infinity is a hard concept to wrap your mind around.
I mean, you take half of infinity, you've got infinity,
you take a third of infinity, you take attempt of infant,
you've got infinity still. So this number,
however big it may seem by human standards,
it's just a little tiny blip in this infinite cosmos. Well,
there was one other assumption that we made and I just maybe I should call
attention to it.
You said that all of the particles that make her up and all of the forces that
join those particles are a finite group.
Um,
and how do you know that all you know is what you can see here where we are.
Why wouldn't you know w who says, well again,
there are underlying assumptions that the laws of physics that we know about
here are the laws of physics that govern the universe everywhere.
That's again a, a rather simple assumption that we don't know to be true.
Certainly our observations of the universe suggests that the parts that we can
see visually are governed by the same laws of physics that govern the phenomenon
that we can see the world around us.
That doesn't prove that if he goes sufficiently far out, the laws might change.
Simplest assumption is that they don't change.
And that's certainly what I am assuming. And then the idea is, you know,
perhaps it's slightly confusing focusing on one individual's particles.
What we really mean is all of the particles in the observable universe,
that part of the universe that can influence itself by virtue of exchanging
particles and exchanging forces.
This particular part of the universe has a certain large number of particles and
that large number of particles has a large number of possible arrangements,
but a finite large number of possible arrangements.
So in most of those arrangements,
there won't be people at all because the particles will be haphazardly arranged
and they want to have coalesced into structures that we call humans and some of
those universities, there'll be one lonely human,
the only person that's formed out of the particles in that universe and a very
tiny fraction. There'll be universes that look like ours. Well,
since you've slipped in this pleural for universe, now, universe says,
let let's cause I don't know that. I should just let you do that.
Let's just do that. When you use the word, when I used the word universe,
I use it in the common sense that it includes everything that we know of or that
we can imagine. That seems to not be even remotely what you're doing. Uh,
well, we found that that notion of universe, however,
all encompassing it sounds,
is a little too coarse to accurately describe modern thinking about how the
physical universe actually works.
And we find it more useful to have words that delineate the universe with finer
characteristics than lumping it all together into everything that you can
imagine. Everything that's out there. So for instance,
we imagine the observable universe that's the part of the universe that you can,
in principle see with a sufficiently powerful telescope with a sufficiently
powerful receiver,
you'd be able to exchange signals with those parts of the universe.
We believe that there are parts of the universe that are just beyond our ability
to see because there's not enough time since the beginning for light or any
other influence to travel from that distant location to us.
So that's a part of the universe that's kind of separate from us.
It's not within the observable universe.
So some people like to think of our observable universe as one contained
universe and those other regions, as in some sense other universes,
they're not that distinct. In principle,
you can get to them if you travel sufficiently far.
They're just regions that are beyond our ability to exchange influence with
today in a Christopher Columbus sort of way, you get on a boat,
you ride to the rise, and you go over the horizon,
you keep going and you'll see something that no one has seen before that you
knew. Yes, hugely. So. In fact, we use the same word horizon,
so just as you mentioned,
Christopher Columbus can look to the horizon and knows that there's something
beyond horizon but can't actually see it.
We look out into the cosmos as far as we can and we believe that there's stuff
beyond what we can see beyond our cosmic horizon.
How much space can we see?
What's the observable? Oh,
roughly 42 billion light years in any given direction. 40 to go. That's the,
that's the the entire diameter. I mean, that's all the way across.
You turned to the left, you look some number that way.
Exactly right. So you look out this way,
you can see about 42 billion lights going to light years,
the best 6 trillion miles. So it's again, it's far, but it's a finite size.
What is your hunch if you do a Columbus,
you go over the horizon and you travel or oh no, let's, let's stay.
If you're in the, the observable universe,
but you move over 800,000 light years to the right.
Right. Um,
so can you now see stuff that people from here couldn't see cause you're now
over there. Oh, absolutely.
You have any sense of whether the stuff you're going to see will be America big
surprise or just more of the same?
Uh, it will in that small motion that you described,
say 42 billion plus light years,
we believe that will be particles,
entities that obey the same laws of physics,
that particles and entities in our observable part behave according to the same
rules. But there'll be configured somewhat differently.
You won't see another America if that's what you're asking out there because
it's so unlikely you need to go far enough away that you sample more possible
configurations and then just one the neighbor next door.
That's as if you said to me,
if I take a coin and I flip it once and I get a particular sequence, heads,
tails, heads, heads, tails. If I flip it a second time,
will I get exactly the same sequence? That's unlikely.
It's possible but unlikely. But if I flipped that five coins sequence,
if I do it a billion times, will I ever get that same sequence? Yes,
very likely.
So if w w is there a place out there where conceivably what is predictable over
here, changes out there. Is there, is there any neighborhood
the laws actually might condemn? Yeah, yeah, absolutely. So in fact,
when we studied modern cosmology with greater intensity,
we find that it's probably likely that if you examine the universe from say a
God's eye view, so using that capital u universe that you started with,
if you can sort of see in some sense the whole thing,
not just what we individual humans have access to it.
Because see the whole thing.
Then you'd probably find according to a theory called inflationary cosmology
that we can discuss if you'd like, but according to this theory,
the likely complexion of the universe is that there are a variety of bubbles,
bubble universes.
Ours is just one of this vast cosmic bubble bath of universes and in the
different bubbles,
the laws of physics can appear to be somewhat different from the laws that we
are familiar with. When you say the they can be different.
So are you talking about Oh,
hydrogen but no oxygen or are you talking about,
oh actually we don't have gravity here and we don't, we don't do gravity.
You know, they don't actually have a weak, for us it's more the former.
But actually the distinction between those two examples is not as clear cut as
you would envision. So for instance,
if you talk about not having the nuclear forces,
which is what you are alluding to,
it's possible that the nuclear forces can be an our universe as we measure them
and in that other bubble universe. But in the other bubble universe,
they might be so weak compared to their strength in our universe that they don't
have much of an impact.
The impact might be infinite Tesla really small compared to the impact in our
world. So for all intents and purposes,
there might not be a nuclear force in that universe compared to the nuclear
force an hours. Although this is getting a little complicated.
So all right,
we're here with a set of rules and a set of operating systems that we have
somehow magnificently begun to figure out.
And then you say they might be a neighbor where all of the principles that we,
that we that have organized life in existence here may not be operating quite
the same way.
But I guess I kind of thought that we here eventually attached to them.
There are these bubbles you talk,
these are different kind of bubble bubbles where we don't attach.
So before when we were talking about the laws of physics here being the same as
the laws of physics, way out where we can see and them beyond the horizon.
Think of that as taking place in one big bubble, right?
When we get to this be easy, ordinary, regular, ordinary. But,
and the thing I really want to stress is these ideas do not come because we
don't have enough to think about.
And the imagination runs wild when we study cosmological data.
And again, I'd be happy to talk about the data,
but I'm not sure how detailed we want to get.
When we study the cosmological data,
it leads us almost an extra bubbly to this picture where there are more than one
bubble and these bubble universes are not talking to one another.
They're not touching each other. You can't reach the other bubble.
You can't traverse the space in between in a meaningful way.
So does that mean that over here, let's say we live here, so we have,
I love this thing, so we are over here,
so that's us.
Now does something come out of this and do it again or does this happen?
And then over there your guy happens.
It's a little high being technical, technically accurate in these questions.
That's like, well let me, let me just say another way of thinking about it that,
that,
that may help and then we can sort of come back to that if you think that will
clarify things. Um, yeah.
The way I thought I was startlingly clear myself. Yeah.
The way I like to think about it is this picture, this inflationary picture,
it's as if the universe is a big block of Swiss cheese.
And I'll just stop right there. Thank you. No,
it's like a big block of Swiss cheese where the holes are the universes that
we're talking about.
So everything that we know about is one hole in the cosmic Swiss cheese.
But there are many other holes in the cosmic Swiss cheese. And the point is,
when we study this picture that emerges from studying the cosmological data,
not from an overworked imagination,
we find that the meaty part of the cheese,
it's sort of a bad vegan man metaphor there, but you know the, um, the white,
the white part of the cheese expand so quickly that the bubbles,
the holes in the cheese are pushed apart at an enormously fast rate,
faster than the speed of light.
And that's what prevents one from even in principle, going from one hole,
one bubble, our universe to another whole another bubble.
So our universe and the other universe is,
they're all embedded in this environment. This cosmetics was cheese,
but we can't traverse the cheesy part because it's growing so enormously
quickly. But oh dear, sweet. Now
let's go with your metaphor here. So we have this big Swiss cheese of,
of a mega something of the place versus is actually the way. Alright,
so now I, we're inside, we're in space. So
this is your cheese hole. Okay.
So I'm living in there, you know, and my universe is getting bigger and bigger.
So this Swiss cheese has he a hole.
That hole is growing.
[inaudible] is growing and you're saying that the cheese but the right part of
the cheese is also growing and it's growing faster than the rate of which that
whole is growing. So there's bigger holes but more cheese.
So if your in this particular thing,
it's brought to you by the American [inaudible] and we'll be doing it in
Wisconsin next week.
So the reason I can't talk to you,
if you're in your hole and I'm mine,
is I'm here growing your over there growing. But the space between us,
we would be flying to either side of this stage. Yes.
Faster than the speed of light. Yes. Fastening the speed of light.
Sometimes people say, well, how's that possible?
And nothing goes faster than the speed of light.
And the thing to remember is that when Einstein established that nothing goes
faster than the speed of light,
but he really established is that nothing can traverse space at a speed greater
than the speed of light.
But as equations full well allows space itself to grow at any speed bigger than
the speed of light is perfectly fine. Okay.
I'm going to keep the keeps coming up because otherwise I'll get completely
lost.
So the universe then is a series of expanding empty spaces inside a web of some
kinds, kind of, we'll call it the big cheese and uh, the, the webs are growing.
What I don't still understand is where did these holes come from in Swiss
cheese? I have no idea where those holes come from me.
I consider this the dual hole problem myself.
What could you address please?
The spacial holes and believe the dairy holes for another occasion. Yeah. So,
so in, in this version of cosmology, again, it's called inflationary cosmology.
What happens is in the beginning,
whenever that means spaces filled with something that we call a field,
an inflow Tom field as the name of it,
and the field is very much like an electromagnetic field that think we're all
pretty much familiar with that idea that there are electromagnetic waves going
through this room.
That's how you can use your cell phone to talk to somebody far away.
The electromagnetic waves are suffusing space.
Those electromagnetic waves are fields, electromagnetic fields.
This inflationary theory invokes a new field,
not the electromagnetic field that fills all of space,
and it has the amazing property that by virtue of filling space,
it causes space to be filled with repulsive gravity.
That's what this field does. Repulsive gravity pushes everything apart.
So this is gravity. Normal gravity brings things together.
This is the ugly twin that's right out of my way, right?
And Einstein himself is the one who found this. This is an old idea.
Repulsive gravity goes back to 1917 even though it's not widely appreciated,
the gravity can be repulsive.
And in this environment of this field filling space, gravity is repulsive,
drives space apart. As space is driven apart.
It turns out that there are regions where this field drops to zero value it.
Quantum fluctuates to zero value, and those are the holes. So we,
our universe is simply a fluctuation in this field where it had a high value and
it dropped to a low value,
thankfully then giving rise to the universe that we are familiar with and as,
let me just close it. As it drops to zero,
it gives up its energy to the familiar particles that make up you and me in the
world.
So all the particles that we know about and this version of cosmology come from
this field dropping down to zero,
releasing its energy to particles that give rise to the stuff that we are
familiar with.
Now that field can drop to zero all over the place giving rise to a bubble
universe here, a bubble universe. They are a bubble universe there.
But in between the fields still has a finite value driving space to expand.
Well, I understood about 5% of that, but,
but maybe 10 so let me say it back to you and tell me how closely here.
So under epic, underneath everything,
there's this Whoa, whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa thing.
Sometimes it gets hot, sometimes it gets cold, it's in flux anyway.
And sometimes it's, it's out this space, get out of my way and create space.
And sometimes it just, I don't know,
it goes home and has a sandwich or something. So, so sometimes you get
an explosion of nothing,
which then melts down into us and sometimes you don't get very much at all.
So you just, and there's this,
this sort of thing underneath everything it's doing as long as by fingering
everything you mean the region of the universe in which this field has a
repulsive gravity effect and drive space to expand.
So the cheesy parts of the Swiss cheese or the places where the field has a
finite value and the holes in the Swiss cheese are where the field has dropped
to zero value. Okay.
So this leads me then infinity, I get on the universe side,
we,
what we end up with then is very distinctly different neighborhoods.
Each of these bubbles can have its own character.
So some of them you could have a Adams that come together happily and form
chains and inform us and they even give rise to intelligent things and other
things you just get like sand or I don't know.
We really boring for us. Yup. Yup. Exactly.
So then the universe is it. Got It. Is this an infinite universe?
This is multi-variable that that's it. That's a good question.
So there are a number of kinds of infinities that now come into the story.
Number one, you can ask how many different bubbles are there,
how many different holes in the cosmetics with cheese are there?
And indeed this is a process that we believe to be eternal and therefore there
would actually be an infinite number of these little bubbles with our bubble
being just one. And now you might say, but wait a second,
you started off this conversation talking about space that we have access to
going on infinitely far. If our universe is a bubble, no matter how big,
it doesn't go on infinitely far, it has some size to it.
And in a way that I urge you not to try to describe in any detail here because
it's pretty tough to someone on the outside.
It looks like this bubble has finite size to anybody on the inside.
It looks like it has infinite size,
so the conversation that we had 15 minutes ago about a universe that goes on
forever applies here even to each of those individual bubbles.
So in each bubble space goes on infinity.
So there are an infinite number of copies of us having this conversation inside
our inside a single one of these bubbles and then you've got infinite number of
bubbles where anything else can be going on. Could there be,
and again again there's a danger, there's a danger that people say, oh my God,
this is so far out and nuts. This is pretty far out. This is,
this is a very minimal,
a very minimal approach to describing observations that we have.
Observations of the cosmic microwave background, radiation,
observations of the early universe by looking deeply into space can only be
understood largely speaking in the context of the frameworks that we're
discussing here. You're saying to me that all these muddy ideas come from very,
very serious premises. Yes. They don't come from people saying,
let's think of another, the idea and examine its consequences.
They come from people saying,
let's do measurements of the universe and try to come up with theories that
explain those measurements.
I'm not even gonna ask you what measurements those were. No,
literally that's not hard to describe.
It's literally measurements of the temperature of radiation that we believe is
leftover from the early stages of our bubble universe.
You measured the temperature over there,
the temperature over there and so forth and you get certain numbers and you try
to explain them with theoretical equations and the framework that is able to
best describe them winds up entailing all of the additional structure that we're
talking about. It comes along with the theory.
It's not something that you put in from the outside. Well,
I want to get as weird as I know how to get here
based on what you've told me before. I, in addition,
imagining now the universe in which there's a bubble in which we have carbon and
hydrogen and oxygen and all the forces that we're familiar with and we have
planets and mass and clouds of gas and you and me over and over and over again,
that universe.
And then we have another universe not too far over on that direction,
which in which very little happens.
And another one in which we get halfway there. And another one,
which is a very odd things happen. What about this?
One of these bubble universes produces super intelligent computer geeks,
intelligent beings. And what they do is they do the matrix.
They come up with a super computer,
a fabulous supercomputer that creates a universe.
So spectacularly realistic that the critters in that phony fake universe think
there are a lot, if you can make,
give me our universe and weird universes and weird or universes,
can you eliminate the possibility of totally fake universe?
Not only can't you eliminate it, it's actually quite likely.
I mean you see in our universe just using that as a benchmark that we're getting
closer and closer to being able to do exactly what you're talking about.
Imagine technology a thousand or 10,000 years or a hundred thousand years down
the road.
One presumes that if progress continues a pace that we will be able to create
the kind of simulations,
computer simulations that to those bits that are being manipulated and that
simulation appears to have a reality in much the same way that you're familiar
from the matrix, you anticipate that that's likely to happen. In fact,
you can go one step further just to what we make sure you show.
The people in this fictive universe would be creatures or fiction made up by a
computer program, but the fiction would be so specific,
so beautifully detailed that these creatures,
fictional creatures in someone's mind to a computer would think they were alive,
would think they fell in love with think that they were having sandwiches,
would think they want it to be Vegas and sure,
but bear in mind that it has nothing specific to do with any of the work that we
physicists and string theorists and cosmologists are working on.
I'm going to take that as a given that the natural progression of technology can
lead to that kind of an outcome.
I have no particular expertise to say that that will happen,
but a glance at the trajectory of technology suggests that that's a possibility.
Now the place where the ideas that we're talking about come in is the following.
If you ask yourself the following question,
is it more likely that if I'm a being that sees a reality,
is it more likely that that's a real reality that came from the universe
creating it and say one of these bubbles or is it more likely that I'm in a
simulation
and all we're talking about here leads to a rather interesting conclusion?
Because for the universe to create a reality that we're familiar with is a
relatively unlikely course of events because the universe is creating all these
bubbles. The particles are coming together in one way or another,
randomly joined together according to the laws of physics and only in some real
tiny fraction will the configurations give rise to human beings say that see a
world akin to the one that we see that's rare.
In one of those bubbles though, if you do have these super intelligent beings,
maybe they're not even super intelligent,
just super expert at dealing with the technology of their time.
If they can create simulated universes,
it's much more direct route to a reality that we would consider akin to what we
experience is not random. It's individuals actually creating the simulation.
In fact, they can create simulation after simulation after simulation,
after simulation. So in that universe, there are many, many,
many simulated worlds that beings in those worlds consider real.
And therefore from that perspective,
they're more simulated worlds that appear like the one that we see around us.
Then there are real ones. Oh No.
So the chances of us being in a naturally occurring real world might be smaller
than the chances that we belong to the fifth grade project of a Geeky kid in the
planet Zan Tar
[inaudible]
I don't know how you live with this stuff and we've only just sat down and
you've already told me that we are doppelganger it up the Gazoo.
We therefore seem to have no real identity. Um,
freewill is an open question and we're probably a fake.
Why didn't you want to become like a soccer player or something were normal?
[inaudible] oh, actually it's a serious question. I mean, do you actually,
uh, do you actually
assuming that you believe these things to be true? Doesn't it get you down?
No, I think it's incredibly exciting. I mean,
to me the most wondrous thing about signs and physics in particular is the fact
that through the power of thought and calculation and observation,
you can be led to conclusions vastly at odds with what you would think based
upon experience.
I don't think there's anything more wondrous in that moment when you think the
world is one way and your equations, your math, your ideas,
your theories begin to convince you that it is another way.
And we've seen this played out in the history of science over and over again.
I mean the,
the gentleman developing quantum mechanics in the twenties and thirties from
Heisenberg to board is Schrodinger and so forth.
They began by thinking that the world was basically a Newtonian world,
a clock work universe as it was called,
where things evolve according to a very precise set of laws.
You tell me how things are today and the clockwork universe tells you how they
will be tomorrow and in a generation they realized that that picture however
compelling was wrong.
They realize that the world arises and develops according to probabilistic
rules.
Where the best you can do is say it's a 30% chance that things will be this way
in an hour, 4% chance of that and 22% of that.
That was such a paradigm shaking way of thinking about reality.
It's not something that gets you down. It's something that pumps you up.
And if we,
and if we are now perhaps learning that the very nature of reality at least
needs to be questioned,
it doesn't in any way stablish that we are in some simulation because it's more
likely perhaps that we are in one. We could still be in a real universe.
But to me it's wonderful to get your sense of reality kicked to get a kick in
the head and to at least be able to contemplate the real possibility that the
laws of physics are suggesting that reality is not what you think it is.
Although if you're seeking to be pleased by what you see,
if you want to feel joy, but I'll give you a joyous image. If,
if I shoot a cannon ball into the air, Newton and wolf physicists can
tell me if they knew enough exactly where the cannon ball is going to go.
And it's fixed and it's understood.
And there the Cannibal has no freewill in this matter.
If you know what the image I like to think is, if I were,
if I took a dead bird and threw it in the air,
it would fall predictably to a place on the ground. But if I took a live bird,
yeah.
And threw it up in the air,
I could in principle predict where it will land. Oh,
but you'd have to know so much. I need to know so much,
but that's a fine detail. That's the fine print you, you,
I think have in mind that the bird has some freewill to go where it wants you to
go. And uh, as far as, as I certainly can tell,
there is no place for free will in our understanding of the laws of physics.
However, diminishing that may make some people feel,
I think we need to perhaps face up to the real possibility that the notion of
having free will is an illusion. It's a useful illusion.
It makes life interesting and it's one that you need to put to the side because
you need to live as though you do have free will.
But all there is is physics.
Um, don't you have, there are a lot of people, uh, Paul Steinhardt, David Gross,
Martin Garden who have some real problems with this multi-verse concept and I'm
just to run a few of them by you. One of them is
to conjure up a universe in which everything that could happen is happening,
you know, so there are lots of Brians in Robertson,
there were lots of almost Brian's in Robertson,
lots of very almost imposed almost in all this kind of thing. Um,
doesn't that break one of the basic rules of science that you to keep it simple
rule outcomes raiser? I mean, if you can, I'll just quote Martin Gardner.
Surely the conjecture that there's just one universe in its creator is
infinitely simpler and easier to believe that there are countless billions upon
billions of worlds.
It does sound simpler in some ways and I have to say,
I'm going to give you two answers to this issue.
If it turns out that our future understanding eliminates this idea of parallel
universes,
multi-verse theory and winds up showing us the way to think about is this,
there's one universe we can calculate everything.
It's uniquely determined by the laws of physics.
I think I'd be happier with that outcome,
so don't get the misunderstanding that I have some emotional connection to this
idea.
It's where we're naturally led by a variety of interesting ideas and therefore
needs to be taken seriously.
But in terms of it being simpler to have one universe versus many,
it really depends on how you define simpler, right?
Is it simpler to have one number versus many or all numbers?
In fact, if I give you a 22 digit number,
just one 22 digit number,
and I ask you to repeat it to me versus I simply say,
think of all numbers and just count them off for me.
Which tasks do you think you will succeed at? Oh, come on,
you make 22 how about working this way? No, no, no.
Give me a two digit number or give me a, but that's the thing.
Our universe is not characterized by a two digit number.
Our University is characterized by a great number of distinct features.
The mass of the electron, the mass of the Cork, this strength of gravity,
the strength of the electromagnetic force.
They gauge symmetry of the standard model,
the equations of general relativity and on and on.
It goes a long list of ingredients that need to be just so for the universe as
we know it to appear.
You get the massive electron a little bit wrong when you repeat it. To me,
the world is different.
You get the strength of gravity a little bit off when you repeat it. To me,
the world is completely different. So there really is a tight analogy.
There's a long number if you will,
that characterizes this data versus their being all universes versus there being
all numbers and in some sense it's much easier from a complexity standpoint to
describe all numbers than it is to describe this one particular 22 or 44 digit
number. In fact,
you can make this precise as a notion of algorithmic complexity,
which is the amount of information necessary to say give to a computer to spit
back a piece of data that you're interested in.
Now I can write a very short computer program that will spit out one, two three,
four, five, six at one line computer code.
If I want to spit out some particular number,
well I may need to actually type in every single digit of that number for it to
spit it back to me. That has greater complexity, not less complexity.
And I'm only trying to emphasize the fact that even though you think of one
universe as being more simple than many,
that reasoning need not actually hold up under close scrutiny.
So just so I give you your due, you are saying that,
and I'm not even gonna ask you what the problems are,
but serious people trying to figure out things that they can measure and things
that they can see and things that they can examine when they look to the math
because I looked behind the math leads them to these two,
this multiple universe concerts directly or over and over and for many,
many different directions from classical physics, from quantum physics.
There are a variety of different ways of having multiple universes.
We've actually described to tonight the idea that if he goes sufficiently far
out, the universe repeats as if there are many worlds out there,
much like ours or there can be these many bubbles where there are many universe
out there that may be like ours or not,
and these are naturally coming from simple ideas that we allow to run their
course. I should emphasize this is not a certainty by any means.
Physics, science,
we all know is that dynamic subject where new ideas come in and force us to
reevaluate and to rethink things.
And I would be thrilled if ultimately we do find that there's one unique
university we can sit down and calculate everything about it that would be
thrilling.
But it's also thrilling to imagine that that isn't how the world is really put
together and that the data that we now have and the ideas that we're coming up
with may be revealing the true underlying reality.
All right, so, so we were left with a bunch of choices. We are,
uh, infinitely duplicatable.
We live in cheese and expanding holes.
He, we might be a reflection of a computer.
We might be a pale reflection of mathematics.
We might be actually made of real stuff in the here and now or not.
[inaudible]
that was professor Brian Green. In conversation with, uh, you, me,
this recording was generously provided by the 92nd street y and they have more
of their electric series available at their website, ww dot 92 y.org.
You can also check out our website while you're online.
Ww Dot Radiolab one word.org media lab is funded by the Alfred p Sloan
Foundation. The Corral Sloan is,
I like to call it the corporation for public broadcasting and the National
Science Foundation. I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.